what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are going to watch
gravity falls season two
episode 14 what's it called john the
stan turian candidate i believe all
right guys you know what to do be sure
to leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated and also um we've partnered
up with a sponsor we are so blessed to
be working with um seriously love this
sponsor love it love it love their
product matter of fact here's why thank
you to helix sleep for sponsoring this
video
so guys as we've been partnering up with
certain brands we've been fortunate
enough to be in the position of work
with brands that we actually truly
believe in and love that is not a
talking point that is me just talking
from my heart right now we are so
fortunate to work with them they
actually make really high quality
premium mattresses customized to fit
your needs conveniently shipped right to
your door uh both john and i each got a
bed the twilight lux it's the second
firmest mattress that they have where i
live now we actually have a back house
and some of you guys might know this i
recently got the vid diesel so to
quarantine you know keep my fiance safe
i stayed in the back house and over
there is where we set up the helix
mattress it was super easy john actually
has footage of him setting up his he
just opened the box on roll it got the
plastic watch it inflate uh two of us
doing it together it only took like less
than 10 minutes it was the easiest bed
setup ever did in my life but sleeping
in that bed i already have a bed in our
master bedroom i did not set up the
helix there because i was like whatever
we just got this bed let's throw it in
the back house
that uh is a decision i will forever
regret
because now we have someone renting that
back house and they get to enjoy that
bed really while i had the vid diesel
while i was recovering it was some of
the best sleep i've ever had my back
actually felt so much better i would
find myself just wanting to be like
maybe i could turn this backhouse into
my own little man cave and i could just
sleep back here and watch tv it is such
a comfy bed i'm telling you guys we are
so fortunate to work with them yeah it's
really easy to get set up you take a
quick quiz online at helixsleep.com they
will match you to the best fit for your
sleep style and they will ship it to you
with a 100 night trial period so if you
don't like it for any reason you could
send it back got a 10-year warranty they
really take the risk out of the whole
situation for you so yeah click that
link in the description box
helixsleep.com rio rejects to save
yourself 200
on your mattress plus you get two free
pillows and free shipping in the united
states oh yeah guys thank you helix for
your support supported them supports us
so yeah all right on to the video
here we go
i needed something to carry milk in so i
used your slippers
dear stan i took these to build a
planetarium suit for seuss
son [ __ ] oh let's not take this line
there's an old person in it
yeah he's probably gonna pay with like
pennies and war bonds hey
and i was gonna shoplift most of this
security
whoa
rough start to a day but it's all gonna
be worth it when i fix that light bulb
and we're done
[Music]
does anyone see this this is what a hero
looks like right here
so i invented my own it will last a
thousand years and the light it emits
makes your skin softer
never have i known such softness anyway
where were you
oh there's other light bulbs in the
house the mayor is dead what whoa what's
going on okay mayor huckaboom
bophustelfunter was best known for
raising the water tower possibly
starting world war one and putting town
menace gideon glee starting world war
one prison
oh my
i'm sorry it's just been so long since
we've had real news i'm just so happy
meeting this afternoon to discuss
replacing him new mayor huh
wonder who it could be
it's pretty obvious who it's going to be
guys all right
hold on everyone
calm down now we're here to choose a
mayor for the first time in almost a
century according to the town charter
and there's anyone who can cast a shadow
count to ten and throw their hat into
the provided ring
[Music]
well now i do no formally announcing my
candidacy for the mayor of gravity falls
any questions are you still in contact
with little gideon great question i'm
giving you 50 off a used car 50 percent
you're a journalist everyone in this
town is a tad strange except ironically
ted strain
pad's the name and being normal is my
game loving you tad and i love bread
good good on you tad live your best life
that's strange and your head is more
ears than face oh yeah well your face is
more fat then
not fat
oh snap what do you think
how about a real election get in there
oh boy did i not make that clear grunkle
stan it's not that we think you can't do
it it's just no no it's okay mabel
we don't think you can do
he can do it dumb brother's research is
probably gonna make him famous and what
do i have to show for my life do i
really want crooked grifter on my
tombstone how about crooked mayor
stable big step up freedom eagle who
will fly to the candidate covered in
more seed and bestow a birdly kiss upon
him anointing him mayor i couldn't make
this up if i wanted to ah the breaker
phone 24-hour news and bear rampage
alerts and now here's the t-man first
question how do you feel about the
american flank i could take it or leave
it too many stripes next question
what would you do to help educate our
kids
simple put them on an island and make
them fight for dominance also teach kids
swears that'll bring them into the real
world
[Laughter]
and get the kid vote crime in general or
just the specific crimes committed by me
candy what's the damage your approval
rating started at zero now it's a number
lower than zero you're memeing fast and
none of them are good
[Laughter]
from now on maybe you should just read
our prepared remarks sorry kids i only
say words that come out of my brain if
my head says that lady's got an ugly
baby my mouth says
lady you got one ugly bait
the stump speech is in a couple of days
and if he continues like this we'll lose
to bud for sure the same there isn't
some device that would allow you to
control someone else a long time ago i
designed a prototype for ronald reagan's
masters just get stand
jesus stripes are so slimming you really
think this mind control tie is gonna
work
oh
i'm a dancing dude i got some fancy
moves and a bad attitude
that is dope i'm really freaked out i am
so strong watch me eat this spine no no
mind control is awesome
oh my gosh my life just flashed before
my eyes oh
hang in there
get it buddy
get it a gravity falls we can be proud
of get it
i want that bumper sticker you think the
women of gravity falls wear too much
makeup
what i meant to say was you ladies all
look great girl you are working it oh
yeah that is exactly what i needed to
hear right now
then we let all those bees loose in that
elementary school a few years back no
but i believe in things america freedom
amerifreedom good he's saying all the
rights
i'm proud to be all here nicely done now
watch me
oh yeah
yeah get in with gen z they're gonna
break his back what is that sound why
are people jamming their hands together
it's applause google stan they love you
they
love me
[Music]
[Applause]
yes we stand
gravity falls being run by a couple of
12 year olds
this is real bad
i need to speak with my campaign manager
please excuse me for a moment
look i'm sorry about all this it is him
oh no you listen daddy and you listen
good prison is a nightmare i hate the
same slop every day they have no hair
products in here i can't sleep because
my sailmaid took my pillow for a wife oh
the mayor dines my one ticket out of
here which is why you're gonna win this
election pardon me out of prison and
we're not gonna let the pines get in my
way again i think he's so gross he is
disgusting
it's your own father you sick bastard
on the house mr big shot now this i
could get used to grunkle stan what's
with the outfit you're missing your
lucky tie power tie gotta
i could debate naked and i'd still win
huh come to think of it oh god seriously
though just keep the tie on with or
without your dumb advice dumb advice
every one of those speeches we were
controlling you
what we need is a blank slate someone
totally suggestible an empty piece of
clay we can mold to our whims
hey a little help dudes i accidentally
got my head stuck in my shirt sleeve i
guess this is my life now
for your favorite candidate by throwing
election seed
welcome all to the final debate in
what's sure to be on a cosmic scale a
forgettable blip in human history
oh hello there stanford long time no see
don't you t hee me i'll debate you into
the ground oh but i have a widow twick
up my sweevey weaves oh man
what's your position on taxes
taxes i propose we stimulate the economy
by waging wars on neighboring cities i
don't know much about taxes but i can
promise you a kitten in every pot you
don't make sense dipper
[Applause]
can't you see what's happening on this
stage these politicians are dancing
around the issues well i
can sing around the issue oh yeah
that's it
that's the whole debate the other guy
didn't even talk when has bud been
creepily adorable i don't know it
doesn't make sense he's almost acting
just like
like widdle oh
me
[Music]
oh no
you've been controlling bud and it seems
you've been controlling stanford i have
to hand it to both of y'all you've
gotten much eviler since i last saw you
no the eye
once i win they'll hit the plunger for
the fireworks display finishing the
mountain's construction trapping y'all
inside i've been trapped behind concrete
all summer now see how you like it
this is not the same thing
ah you're dying out there stan
what the we're tied to a bunch of
fireworks
[Music]
save them it'll get your approval
ratings up
kids
everyone loves a family man everybody
this debate is over i got to go save my
family those those are just some
demolition dumbest nothing to see here
can it gleeful
[Music]
stan pines has run to the aid of two
children who appear to be in danger the
crowd is loving it no stop it thank you
but stop it ah get back you terror birds
oh
[Music]
goddamn american hero i guess being the
town's hero wasn't enough i wanted to be
yours too we're sorry uncle stan we
should have supported you win or lose
probably lose i can still drop you you
know
oh no we have to get out of here kids
if i die
make sure i get a bigger tombstone than
ford
[Music]
they're picking it
it's the justice signal
despite winning an overwhelming 95 of
the vote election officials had to
disqualify him due to discovery of an
extensive criminal record what didn't i
do crimes include shoplifting teaching
bears to drive a new crime
[Laughter]
burgle bezelman first degree llama side
that llama new tomb llamas
too much
grunkle stan are you crying i got
campaign confetti in my eye come on kids
want to go vandalize mayor tyler's
mansion
vandalism
i'm sorry the election thing didn't work
out for you bro but if it makes you feel
any better we're gonna throw riot
tonight does someone want to throw a
riot
thanks ghost eyes i'm just not in the
mood this poster is the only thing
keeping me going
oh
[Music]
the time has come prepare yourselves
for the beginning of the end
all right john take it away this episode
was inspiring to me i want to run for
office fourth with
this was fun this was like a fun uh it's
california people adore mayors they do
out here in los angeles people are like
who's the new mayor every day uh-huh
it's it's it's it really is a
celebration
to this day i know who the mayor is it's
the most supportive office you can have
yeah you like the mayor right definitely
love our current mayor yeah whose name
we both
most certainly are aware of yeah
so
why don't you comment your support for
our mayor down below in the comments and
these small town things it seems like
mayors are a big deal
well yeah i mean it seems like that's
where like the real politics that are
gonna affect you come down from
i would imagine
i have no idea
me neither
i think uh i think i know our governor
governor newsom
yeah
not
rudy giuliani
you you wish buddy you wish i do life
would be a lot more entertaining
and uh yeah
i guess this was this was a good one
it was funny yeah it was a funny
fast-paced one that didn't feel entirely
essential other than the final moments
which is like a setup for something that
feels essential yeah because i was like
this is kind of a weird one off it's
such a sick calm type of episode for you
know hey watch as this character runs
for mayor like it's such a such a sitcom
episode yeah you know the status quo
isn't gonna change that much yeah yeah
but i like how it came around to because
because it came around to the end would
you know saving dipper and mabel
which was very heartfelt and
you know does show the trajectory of how
much stan has grown over this show
and uh that's kind of like i like soft
sand i do i like the balance of it as
opposed to just leaning into the pure
aggressive nature
of him but damn i don't want that tie
that tie would be awesome that would be
so cool it might control people like
that do they have a tie like that you
gotta have something remember pinky in
the brain when peeking around i think
for mayor he had these glasses and brain
was feeding him words to read so he
could re he just had to keep the glasses
on he could read it
i've always loved stuff like that
technology to control and manipulate the
public that's what i've always wanted
dude that you should you should pursue
that you should dump all of your your
life's worth into into developing that
tech because think i mean so many people
would want to use it would want to get
in on that it would be like a trillion
dollar idea who needs a million dollar
idea
i could pull it off yeah
and then you could probably use it to
kind of gain control of the the planet
at large yeah create an effort called
gaslighting
it's coming along great
kids look at what gaslighting is i
guarantee you you master that power at
an early age you have no idea what
you're capable of
you're crazy no one's mind controlling
you
but yeah i mean gideon gideon has always
creeped me out like in a really like
you're
you're creepy like you you find you icky
and repulsive and uh
like i don't like gideon
not like oh because gideon's a character
you're not supposed to like
i
i really don't like him
yeah it makes me uncomfortable to look
at and to listen to yeah i guess that's
the point but i've never really found
him i'm not bored around him
i'm just like
i feel he's like the rare cartoon
character i can smell
you know like he smells bad what does he
smell like he smells like [ __ ] like he
just smells like bad b.o
and pomade
too much pomade
i guess
he looks like the kind of guy who would
where so much product would have the
this disgusting like sweaty pits yeah
yeah yeah he thinks the product makes up
for the whole rest of his body when it
does breath would smell yeah
and and i just
look i'm getting at it as he
has not his gravity falls so i try to
cut back my language a little bit i'm
gravity falls but
he feels like a pervert
ryan sure he feels like a little dab
both feel like perverts
kitty and way more feels like a pervert
than his dad well yeah i'd hang out with
his dad any day of the week
gideon not so much
well yeah and i feel like there's part
of that too is the first time we met him
i think both of us were like wait a
minute is this guy a kid or an adult and
i think that always has lingered that
just like i know now you're a kid
but you don't feel 100 like a kid which
just adds to the sort of
ickiness of everything he does it's
disgusting yeah
but why do people wanna i mean
is being mayor in a small town really
all that different
from being the mayor of a big town like
what do you do you really make changes
you probably you probably are more
influential negotiate on behalf of your
township and whatever so probably i mean
like you're probably the one who's
getting the greater state to help out
with such and such you know we gotta
improve our infrastructure or whatever
else i feel like i can move to a small
town in 10 years be the mayor oh yeah
you would you would absolutely be able
to do that i feel like if you walk in
the park you probably probably would all
these boring ass small towns you know
how to lead people and you know how to
inspire people i don't even mean you
know and you know how to do you're not
gonna do any of that and you know how to
take people as they are and like
motivate them yeah yeah shut the [ __ ] up
what you gotta do is
learn to inspire and be kind to people
i'm taking notes right now
taking some notes down this is great
information for me to learn from
you got my vote i wouldn't dare vote for
anybody i'd be your most sarcastic mayor
but people would would like that i think
i think it would be um
they just gotta have an interesting
personality
mostly a small town folk
bunch of dull
little weeds
should be plucked out of the earth don't
worry none of you people who watch are
from a small are in a small town right
now nope you can't you don't have to you
don't have internet that helps you to
support watching a 20-plus minute
youtube video where you're at if you
live in a small town
so yeah you probably can't see or hear
this we're just a few big blocks
we're in we're in 15p resolution right
now uh no i mean it would be fun though
sure it seems like the most
potential for fun a political office
could hold because you're not too high
up
i would install a
multicultural whenever i travel to small
towns sometimes i don't feel like
there's enough
cultural
restaurants
oh sure like there's the one
restaurant that has
mexican food
on their menu yeah
there's the one where you can get
mexican there's the one where you can
get pizza and
noodle italian dishes there's the one
where you can get maybe like a a
homogenized just bunch of asian foods
all mixed together
i would love a diner i think it'd be i
think i regretted it you would be great
at it you actually would be great at it
i don't know the first thing about
actual political stuff doesn't matter
it's all negative things a small town
doesn't matter small towns they don't
know what the hell they're doing out
there yeah man just go watch welcome to
moose port take a few notes and you're
ready to go i don't care why they work
so hard
what i would do is develop some
infrastructure i would uh
bring some business over there
some real some real business
build a town build a supermarket
a vast supermarket perhaps a mall
you know
open the town up for like film crews and
stuff you know like boost the economy
that way yes and i think that always
makes small towns happier they love that
yeah so
city folk like coming in bringing their
own perspectives and lives in you get it
you get it and what i would also do is
buy up some property from people who
have been there for so so long because
some of them have been there way too
long
and a lot of those people
just need to be booted out man go learn
share sure gotta learn to move from
their small town and experience life
some of those people have been living
there for generations like their great
great grandfather
and
after a while you're like dude you got
to do something more with your legacy go
outside there's money to be made out
there and adventures to be had
so stop chopping down your trees
and living in your unair conditioned
home
eating crops you grew yourself it's
disgusting with your freaking beans in a
boiling pot that you that's not even
boiled on a stove boiled outside under
actual fire
poor pathetic
you guys
oh you small town [ __ ] oh
po dunk hay seeds out there
yeah i can hear everybody's computers
closing
but yeah they're restarting it because
they can't because they're headed to
watch the video
give up on this video and i gotta go
vote for craig
yeah
do you see the right information got
through even if they couldn't load
everything
i would love to go to a small town again
you should go
they're the best
because the supermarkets are always like
you know five miles away
yeah there's only one central place
where everything is and nothing stays
open past like nine or ten yeah it's my
favorite favorite
aspect of it yeah i'm hungry at this
hour i got one option everyone goes to
bed at the same time
not bad one 24-hour restaurant or
24-hour like convenience store where i
could get a microwave burrito i guess
that's it
anyway
since this episode wasn't that
substantial that's what we talked about
today
substandard there was also some north by
northwest vibes in here that's my stray
observation for the day
a little bit by northwest yeah isn't
that the alpha red hitchcock movie
you can't
uh
i don't know what's more innocuous than
no it's all just words i shouldn't say
in this video
this is why you cannot run for me i
shouldn't no one should trust me to run
for mayor right now
it's going to be a very disorganized
city
although there is a lot of real estate
to be made in some of these small towns
oh sure
land
tear down some trees uh-huh build some
properties yeah
dig in and excavate you know like dig
dig down deep you can make like a
big-ass parking garage or something
think how many people you could park in
your small town all in the same one
location
get all the cars and be a good mayor
yeah
all you need is a slogan
good poster you know maybe a commercial
or two and public access oh my god i
could edit a better campaign video on
freaking imovie you could than
any of these
dial up folk know how to do yeah yeah
absolutely you could with your high
speed internet that's what you the first
thing you should bring to the small town
is be like we're gonna let verizon or
whoever contract here to bring high
speed actually that's what elon musk's
internet's for works better in places
like small towns oh that's cool good for
him yeah glad something's genius
sexual deviant too
yeah among various other things
people give him too much crap he's done
a lot of great things
he invented the electric car that's
right he himself engineered the tesla he
built space uh-huh
yeah and uh and uh two i mean all of the
underground uh rail systems i would
build an elon musk museum
you should
and everybody pays through paypal to get
in
why because uh
you know why not does he own paypal
that's where his fortune came from i
thought he sold paypal oh well i mean he
did own it and then he sold it yeah
i got well his real fortune comes from
uh apartheid emeralds apparently but
but you know paypal's the first big
business venture he is notified
fox foxy fox
fox listen
it's important that
as i run for mayor
they're going to be expecting me to have
uh
someone by my side a partner a companion
now olivia doesn't like uh being in the
public eye too much
so fox
just something there's nothing
nothing intimate
just for show
i think i'm gonna need to be my public
wife
okay okay
be by my side
helping me run things yeah just off of
appearances you know we'll hire some
kids to pretend to be our children
go out to dinner you know hey walking
through the local denny's look how
humble they are denny's with all the
money they have
as mayor family
of
this town yeah
fox
there's a lot of money we can make
together oh yeah you're testing really
well with all the the appropriate
demographics you have the exact look
of just
diverse enough but also not diverse too
much
to the point where
you will be accepted by most people
and i think
that if you're willing to embark
on this venture with me
who knows maybe one day you can have a
real family yourself
when i let you yes yeah when you decide
to retire just you know as a contract
eight year contract yeah
because then we have to have a big
public divorce
right because when we have to be
i'm planning on being there for like
five years okay
then i need a big public divorce because
it's gonna make us relevant again yeah
all right you get that extra three years
out of your contract then unfortunately
i'm gonna have to shame you just a
little bit remember it's nothing
intimate nothing personal in the
contract it's all
just for optics public appearance really
no actual judgment of my own against
your
character after i'm done shaming you in
the public
then i'm going to take the kids the kids
have hired
and they're going to have to out you too
but there's a big payday coming for you
oh yeah and i'm telling people it's
gonna be really easy for you to find a
man after that or a woman i don't know
which way you swing yeah
no people people love uh the the the the
you know figures that the focus of
political intrigue and nasty public uh
yeah personal life i'm trying to find
someone that's what people are drawn to
to be my wife
for the
primarily heterochristian red state that
i
am
running for which state is that
um
it's new
that's good let's see this is your
opportunity to get in the ground floor
of a brand new the 51st state yeah you
have to make whole new flags now texas
has been trying to separate from the us
for i think 60 years yes
maybe longer i'm gonna make that happen
do it that's the first thing as mayor
mayor as mayor of whatever state you're
in i'm gonna kick texas out of the union
so fox
i hope you're ready because um
it's about to get wild
in a
very business way yes
business wild
[Music]
you